ein urteil mit folgen der
bundesnachrichtendienst verstößt bei der
überwachung im ausland gegen grundrechte
ein plan mit problemen das deutsch
französische anti- corona hilfspaket
spaltet die eu und ein befund der sorgen
macht vielen tier und pflanzenarten in
deutschland geht es schlecht
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten an diesem dienstag darf
der bundesnachrichtendienst ausländer im
netz überwachen ohne anlass wohlgemerkt
dagegen hatten ausländische investigativ
journalisten und reporter ohne grenzen
geklagt nein das darf er nicht sagt nun
das bundesverfassungsgericht und
entschied damit zum ersten mal dass
grundrechte wie
telekommunikationsgeheimnis und
pressefreiheit nicht nur für
bundesbürger sondern auch für ausländer
hier und im ausland gelten christoph
schneider
sie ist eine der klägerinnen journalist
in cadiz meiler war in aserbaidschan
ihrem heimatland hat sie
korruptionsskandale auf höchster
regierungsebene aufgedeckt ist dabei
auch auf informanten angewiesen
sie befürchtet dass ihre kommunikation
vom bnd überwacht wird und hat
verfassungsbeschwerde eingelegt
wenn wir journalisten unter überwachung
stehen können wir informanten kein
schutz gewährleisten und so werden sich
informanten nicht mehr an uns wenden
weil dies für sie nicht sicher ist die
überwachung der kommunikation von
ausländern im ausland durch den bnd
ein teil des datenstroms aus e mails und
telefongesprächen wird neben dem
empfänger auch an den bnd geleitet
kommunikation an der in länder beteiligt
sind darf der bnd nicht abfangen
auch filter der bnd die datenmassen
automatisch mit select ohren so greift
der kommunikation ab in der bestimmte
begriffe auftauchen oder die aus
krisengebieten stammt doch diese
massenhafte sammlung und auswertung sie
geht so nicht grundrechts
einschränkungen müssen klar benannt
werden so das bundesverfassungsgericht
die derzeitige gesetzliche regelung ist
wegen verstoßes gegen das zitiergebot
formell verfassungswidrig und steht auch
inhaltlich nicht im einklang mit
zentralen verfassungsrechtlichen
anforderungen der gesetzgeber hat jedoch
die möglichkeit die gesetzlichen
grundlagen der ausland ausland
fernmelder aufklärung verfassungskonform
auszugestalten
die strategische auslands überwachung
ist weiterhin möglich muss aber künftig
gesetzlich deutlich begrenzt werden
bis ende 2021 hat der gesetzgeber zeit
hier um
nachzubessern also striktere regeln und
mehr kontrolle für den
bundesnachrichtendienst wie kommt dieses
urteil in berlin und bei betroffenen an
erstaunlicherweise sind die reaktionen
auf allen seiten positiv vor allem die
kläger sehen darin einen meilenstein im
schutz von journalisten und eine
stärkung der menschenrechte weltweit
thomas reichert berichtet berlin
reagiert auf das karlsruher urteil mit
einem alten reflex jeder findet es gut
die große koalition die für das bnd
gesetz stimmte das nun reformiert werden
muss ebenso die regierung wir wollen
dass der bundesnachrichtendienst das
vertrauen der bevölkerung besitzt dass
ihn alle als ein sicherheitsorganen
wahrnehmen was unsere deutschen
interessen schützt und dass es deshalb
auch erforderlich ist dass er höchsten
rechtlichen maßstäben gerecht wird
das ist ein anspruch den haben wir
selber und deshalb werden wir das urteil
umsetzen ändern muss sich die
zusammenarbeit des bnd mit anderen
geheimdiensten für die weitergabe von
daten soll nun besondere
schutzvorkehrungen gelten für die
umsetzung bleibt nicht viel zeit dem
parlament im herbst nächsten jahres ist
schon bundestagswahl
insofern kann man nur hoffen wenn sich
jetzt die große koalition auf macht
dieses urteil umzusetzen dass man
diesmal sozusagen nicht so grob
fahrlässig vorgeht sondern sehr viel
präziser arbeitet kaum einer befürchtet
heute eine wirkliche schwächung des bnd
die überwachung der speer aber wird
stärker auch durch ein unabhängiges
kontrollgremium wir bekommen sicherlich
eine gestärkte kontrolle der
nachrichtendienste bei gleichwohl
fortwirkende möglichkeit etwa des bnd
und des wasserschutzes auch ihren
aufgaben nachzukommen das ist eine ganz
wichtige botschaft sicher scheint zudem
dass nach diesem urteil auch die
volksvertreter den geheimdienst noch
genauer werden überwachen können
ein wegweisendes urteil felix zimmermann
ist da aus unserer redaktion recht und
justiz felix das heißt also die
grundrechte gelten nicht nur für
deutsche für bundesbürger sondern
tatsächlich für jedermann das
grundrechte für jedermann auch für
ausländer in deutschland gelten das ist
immer anerkannt aber das neue und
historische ist eben das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat erstmals
festgestellt
ausländer können sich auch im ausland
auf grundrechte berufen
ja und das bedeutet eben der
bundesnachrichtendienst darf sie nicht
so behandeln als wären sie rechts los
darf sie nicht die global überwachen und
pauschal und das ist natürlich ein
starkes zeichen ein starkes signal für
menschen- und grundrechte was das
bundesverfassungsgericht ihr aussendet
das heißt die grundrechte werden also
gestärkt aber die arbeit des bnd macht
das nicht einfacher oder ja genau also
wir die politischen stimmen hören die
anderen positiv reagieren die wahrheit
ist natürlich der bnd ist dann erheblich
geschwächt er hat weniger macht wenige
weniger befugnisse darf eben diese
auslands überwachung nicht wie bisher
fortsetzen und so ehrlich muss man sich
dann auch machen die ein oder andere
sicherheitsrelevante informationen
die kann dann möglicherweise am bnd auch
vorbeigehen
doch muss man natürlich sehen also eine
totale sicherheit die könnte es ja
allenfalls in einem überwachungsstaat
geben und den gibt unser freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung natürlich
nicht her und von daher glaube ich dass
hier das uns verfassungsgerichten diese
austarierung zudem feiert interessen und
sicherheitsinteressen eine kluge
entscheidung getroffen hat vielen dank
dass sie uns das angeordnet haben felix
zimmermann 500 milliarden für den
wiederaufbau in europa ein großartiges
zeichen der solidarität oder einbruch
mit eu recht
die deutsch französische initiative
stößt auf ein geteiltes echo
einige länder pochen darauf dass brüssel
nur kredite und keine zuschüsse ausgibt
für merkel und makro heißt dass
überzeugungsarbeit leisten
denn der plan muss von allen 27 eu
staaten einstimmig beschlossen werden
aus brüssel stefan leifert das
deutsch-französische bedürfnis neue
unzertrennlich kite zu demonstrieren
macht auch vor videotechnik keinen halt
die finanzminister feiern den vorstoß
der europa wieder einen soll dieser neue
500 milliarden fonds wird uns in die
lage versetzen dass europa gemeinsam aus
der krise wächst und auch wieder stärker
wird
das glaube ich ist eine sehr gute
botschaft dies ist ein historischer
schritt für frankreich und deutschland
und ein historischer schritt für die
gesamte europäische union
historisch vor allem weil angela merkel
grünes licht für gemeinsame schulden gab
ein novum in europa 500 milliarden euro
soll die eu aufnehmen und als
zuwendungen verteilen
erstmals würden alle mitgliedstaaten
über den eu haushalt gemeinsam schulden
aufnehmen und abbezahlen um den
krisengebeutelten ländern südeuropas zu
helfen die kritik daran kam prompt hier
soll eine 180 grad kehrtwende gemacht
werden dass plötzlich die europäische
union jetzt doch sich verschulden darf
ich bin sehr skeptisch ob es überhaupt
dazu kommt dass aus diesen plan etwas
wird 25 eu länder müssen jetzt überzeugt
werden südeuropa um italiens premier
konnte ist schon im boot um österreich
sebastian kurz formiert sich widerstand
von ländern des nordens sie sind gegen
zuschüsse wollen anders als merkel makro
höchstens kredite gewähren
der deutsch französische plan hat das
zeug dazu die wunden zu heilen die
korona zwischen den eu-ländern gerissen
hat merkel makro sind über ihren
schatten gesprungen doch bis aus dem
plan wirklichkeit wird stehen in brüssel
noch harte kämpfe bevor auch nach wochen
intensiver forschung bleibt das corona
virus für ärzte und wissenschaftler
rätselhaft warum zum beispiel verläuft
die krankheit so unterschiedlich vier
besonders betroffene orte schaut sich
das robert-koch-institut jetzt genauer
an
um das virus besser zu verstehen die
kleine gemeinde kupferzell in nordrhein
westfalen macht den anfang 2000 menschen
werden dort getestet und befragt thomas
kollision zwischen grünen hügeln ein
trügerisches idyll denn kupferzell ist
ein corona hotspot massen infektionen
gab es nirgendwo in baden württemberg im
schnitt so viele
nun soll die kleine gemeinde große hilfe
leisten im kampf gegen das virus 2000
ausgewählte der 6000 einwohner sind
aufgerufen sich testen zu lassen das
robert koch institut
wir wissen wie viele menschen haben
antikörper gebildet wer ist häufiger
betroffen und was treibt eine
ausbreitung voran
das lka untersucht das bald in drei
weiteren betroffenen orten repräsentativ
für deutschland ist die studie nicht
aber dann haben wir schon einen eindruck
dahingehend ob bestimmte ergebnisse
ähnlich sind also ob wir immer wieder
feststellen es sind die gleichen
faktoren die dazu beitragen dass das
ausbruchsgeschehen sich sehr schnell und
dynamisch entwickelt hat bundesweit geht
der trend nach unten im 7 tagesschnitt
haben sich 570 menschen täglich neu
angesteckt insgesamt sind mehr als 177
1000 infizierte registriert davon gelten
mehr als 155.000 als genesen 8000 67
menschen sind in verbindung mit cupid 19
gestorben und politik und wissenschaft
warnen weiter vor das virus zu
unterschätzen ärzte berichten nun von
schwersten co wird verläufen von
querschnittslähmungen von leber und
nierenversagen definitiv nicht zu spaßen
kupferzell hält abstand genug hat man
hier erlitten die erfahrungen daraus
soll corona wenigstens eindämmen helfen
und eine kleine korrektur natürlich mein
wer kupferzell in baden württemberg
natürlich nicht in nordrhein westfalen
schauen wir nach schweben das land gilt
für viele als beispiel dafür dass man
der korona pandemie auch ohne
flächendeckende einschränkungen begegnen
kann als bei uns geschäfte und
restaurants geschlossen waren hat
schweden auf freiwilliges abstand halten
gesetzt
jetzt zeigt sich dort sind umgerechnet
auf die einwohnerzahl etwa 3,8 mal so
viele menschen in verbindung mit cobit
19 gestorben wie in deutschland vor
allem ältere herrmann bernd berichtet
kein lockdown freiwilligkeit statt
verbote schwedens wie beachteter
sonderweg in sachen corona doch gerade
der schutz alter menschen ist misslungen
die zahl der opfer in
pflegeeinrichtungen viel zu hoch
beklagen pflegekräfte wie elisabeth an
volk wenn wir schon früher wie sie und
mundschutz getragen hätten hätten wir ja
eine barriere zwischen uns und den alten
menschen gehabt hätte man das virus ganz
draußen halten wollen hätte man ab dem
ersten tag personalen testen müssen
3700 todesfälle aktuell mehr als die
hälfte davon in alten und pflegeheimen
sagt an folgt die auch
gewerkschaftssprecherin ist in diesen
wochen bestätige sich dass die pflege
älterer menschen zu lange vernachlässigt
wurde
krone habe die mängel im system offen
gelegt es gibt so viele zeit angestellte
die im pflegebereich arbeiten und
dadurch ist es noch anstrengender
wenn man eine zeit anstellung hat muss
man mehrere jobs haben damit das geld
reicht dreimal so viele todesfälle wie
bei den skandinavischen nachbarn vor
allem in den altenpflegeeinrichtungen
schweden sonst so selbstbewusste
behörden gestehen probleme in diesem
punkt ein
ja dieser bereich ist schon vorher sehr
kritisiert worden
man hat schon vorher qualitätsmängel
entdeckt wichtig ist dass man jetzt
daraus lernt uns gemeinsam in schweden
eine mehr hochqualitative alterspflege
schafft mehr tests mehr geld für das
personal so reagiert die schwedische
regierung auf die krise
die infektionszahlen in den heimen
scheine nun auch tatsächlich zu sinken
zu spät sagen viele in schweden nach
washington wo us-präsident trump seine
angriffe auf die
weltgesundheitsorganisation weiter
verschärft er werde die us zahlungen
endgültig einstellen und die
mitgliedschaft überdenken wenn sich die
bhu nicht schnell zu wesentlichen
verbesserungen verpflichtet trump dürfte
wie hello fehler bei der bewältigung der
korona pandemie vor etwa einen zu china
freundlichen kurs am nachmittag
beschloss die
weltgesundheitsorganisation auf ihrer
jahrestagung der weltweite umgang mit
der korona krise und die arbeit der wehr
so sollen unabhängig untersucht werden
trump und di bello ein ziemlich
verkorkste verhältnis elmar theveßen in
washington bleibt das nun so für alle
zeiten oder könnte trump auch noch
einlenken
also er hat vorhin hier im weißen haus
jedenfalls gesagt die whu muss jetzt
erst mal richtig aufräumen aber das
weiße haus begrüßt diese untersuchungen
die jetzt vorgesehene ist als ersten
wichtigen schritt ist soll jetzt nur
auch schnell angegangen werden
ich glaube es gibt hier so eine einsicht
dass die wirtschaftlichen kosten einer
pandemie so hoch sind dass es immer noch
günstiger ist dann am ende in die whu
für prävention zu investieren aber die
usa knüpfen dass ein sehr sehr klare
bedingungen
sie wollen dass künftig schon
alarmierungs stufen vorhanden sind also
dass schon alarmiert wird lange bevor
die pandemie dann ausgerufen würde
sie fordern eine komplette kontrolle der
länder die einen ausbruch zu verzeichnen
haben oder eines lehnen sie rundweg ab
das ist nämlich wenn länder impfstoffe
jetzt entwickeln zum beispiel auch gegen
coop 19
dann lehnen sie ab dass die rechte an
diesen impfstoffen mit allen anderen
geteilt werden sollen wenn diese
bedingungen nicht erfüllt werden dann
kann es absolut sein dass die usa ob das
nun klug ist oder nicht wirklich aus der
whu aussteigen und die gelder komplett
streichen
vielen dank rt wissen nach washington
nach den usa entwickelt sich jetzt
lateinamerika zum neuen corona
brennpunkt in einigen ländern gelten
seit wochen drastische ausgangssperren
in chile gab es jetzt gewalttätige
proteste dagegen die demonstranten
verlangen lebensmittelpakete von der
regierung sie dürfen seit einem monat
nicht mehr zur arbeit gehen viele
chilenen haben in dieser situation
keinerlei soziale absicherung
etwas licht und viel schatten gibt es im
bericht zur lage der natur in
deutschland denen bundesumweltministerin
schulze heute vorgestellt hat
schauen wir erst einmal auf die wenigen
guten nachrichten die renaturierung von
flüssen und auen geht voran buchenwälder
erholen sich und in siedlungen und welt
dann gibt es wieder mehr vögel wie zum
beispiel den buntspecht doch auf der
anderen seite bedroht vor allem die
intensive landwirtschaft viele arten
florian haben berichtet zu erkennen ist
ein rebhuhn leicht an seinem orange
braunen kopf zu sehen aber hierzulande
immer seltener
der bestand in den letzten 25 jahren um
90 prozent gesunken ein dramatischer
rückgang der so sagt die
umweltministerin heute vor allem eine
ursache hat das ist die intensive
landwirtschaft es gibt zu viel dünger zu
viele pestizide auf den wiesen und
weiden wird zu viel gedüngt und soviel
gemäht dass diese flächen für die natur
immer wertloser werden alle sechs jahre
erfasst deutschland einer eu-vorgabe
zufolge die lage der natur als günstig
wird die situation nur noch bei 25
prozent der untersuchten arten
eingeschätzt etwa beim steinbock als
unzureichend bei 30 prozent etwa beim
fischotter als schlecht bei 33 prozent
insbesondere bei insekten und
schmetterlingen wie dem apollofalter
dass insekten sterben beunruhigt
naturschützer wir brauchen die insekten
für unsere ernährung sie sind unsere
bestäuber wir brauchen vor allem eine
veränderung der pflanzenschutz
verordnung und da muss politik handeln
insektenschutz ein aktionsprogramm dazu
hatte die bundesregierung bereits 2019
beschlossen
noch in diesem jahr verspricht die
ministerin heute soll ein gesetz folgen
schulze setzt auch auf ein umdenken
durch die korona pandemie
ich habe darum die hoffnung dass wir den
naturschutz als medizin gegen die krise
begreifen und als impfstoff gegen die
nächste pandemie
denn je mehr der mensch in die natur
vordringen desto größer weltweit das
risiko dass viren von der tierwelt auf
den menschen übergehen
warum insekten so wichtig sind auch für
die landwirtschaft zeigen wir ihnen in
der zdf- heute- app am beispiel der
bienen klicken sie sich durch
interessante informationen bis zu der
frage was jeder einzelne für die bienen
tun kann
vor genau einem halben jahr wurde fritz
von weizsäcker sohn des früheren
bundespräsidenten in berlin erstochen
heute hat der prozess gegen den mann
herzlichen mörder begonnen der 57
jährige soll aus hass auf die familie
von weizsäcker gehandelt haben
der täter hatte den renommierten
mediziner während eines vortrages
getötet und dabei auch einen polizisten
schwer verletzt
zum sport und da soll es nach dem
fussball nun auch in der basketball
bundesliga weiter gehen
das vorgelegte hygiene concert concept
habe überzeugt so die bayerische
landesregierung
der meister wird nun in einem
mehrtägigen turnier in münchen ermittelt
mehr von peter leissl der deutschen
basketball die geister ein treffer
geglückt das konzept für eine beendigung
der saison von der politik genehmigt
münchen die stadt des aktuellen
deutschen meisters bayern wird also im
juni schauplatz eines finalturniers
zuschauer bleiben draußen wenn zehn
mannschaften nach folgendem modus den
meister ermitteln
eine vorrunde mit zwei fünfergruppen
dann viertel und halbfinale im hin und
rückspiel schließlich zwei finalspiele
ziel ist nach wie vor an am 28
juni sonntag soll auch ganz gut passen
eben das zweite finalspiel im rücken
playoffs das zweite finale zu spielen
das hygiene konzept der liga überzeugte
komplette isolation aller zehn
mannschaften in einem hotel pendelt zum
spiel und zur trainingshalle drei wochen
lang die teams befinden sich derzeit im
dreiwöchigen aufbautraining vorerst nur
in kleinen gruppen wie hier in bamberg
das investieren wir auch nicht also
investieren das turnier siebenstellig
als liga das ist so kein jux und das ist
schon eine ernsthafte auch business
entscheidung anders als im handball
eishockey oder volleyball haben die
basketballer ein eigenes konzept
verfolgt es verspricht ein sportlich
faires saisonende wahrscheinlich mit
größerem medieninteresse als in früheren
zeiten
und zum schluss haben wir noch eine neue
episode aus der reihe tiere in corona
zeiten in kansas city in den usa haben
pinguine einen ausflug ins für menschen
geschlossene kunstmuseum gemacht die
vögel
auf caravaggio viel stärker reagiert als
auf die werke von monet hieß es vom
museum allen habe es ganz ausgezeichnet
gefallen
inwieweit die museumsleute das
beurteilen können ist eine andere frage
nach mit empathie geht es zum wetter das
bleibt zunächst warm und trocken wann es
regnet erfahren sie gleich von özden
terli so viel von uns für den moment
claus kleber und das heute journal um
viertel vor zehn
wir danken für ihr interesse und
wünschen noch einen schönen abend bis
morgen
[Musik]
ein guter abend und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter ruhiges hochdruckwetter
herrscht weiterhin und auch in den
kommenden tagen dazu kommt immer wärme
luft aus dem südwesten zu uns und so
steigen die temperaturen sogar noch
etwas an
in der nacht gibt es wenige wolken an
der ostsee aber sonst nach westen ist es
kompakter bewirkt genau so wie richtung
erzgebirge ein paar schauer gibt es an
den alpen bei temperaturen von 4 bis 13
grad das sind die tiefs werte morgen
sind die wolken ähnlich verteilt nach
westen in richtung emsland mehr wolken
und auch im erzgebirge und im südosten
hier fällt sogar etwas regen raus an der
ostsee viel sonnenschein und auch ganz
im südwesten scheint für längere zeit
die sonne die temperaturen erreichen
dabei 15 grad an der ostsee und 24 bis
26 grad im südwesten
den kommenden tagen wird es noch wärmer
temperaturen steigen am himmelfahrtstag
bis 28 grad freitag bis 30 und samstag
gibt es dann schauer und gewitter ein
schöner abend